[Music]
good morning buenos dias
it is
6 30 in the morning and today is isaac's
birthday it's turning 14. we're still
trying to wake up but um we're up this
early
to try to make them breakfast and try to
decorate for his birthday
and i'm whispering so he doesn't hear us
so
let's get started
[Music]
[Applause]
happy birthday
to
you
happy birthday
to you
happy birthday my 14 year old
can't believe you're 14 dude yeah it's
crazy
[Music]
yay thank you for finishing the song
baby you came down too fast i didn't get
enough time to put more balloons
there's just two balloons
it's symbolic of your teenage years your
two balls have dropped oh my
so while i was decorating uh dad made
you breakfast he made you an egg burrito
oh yeah look at these cute little
pom-pom too and then i made this cheesy
pudding last night let me know if you
like it okay thank you dad for the
burrito
i love the decorations mom yeah symbolic
meaning
now i'll add more balloons i'll look for
it it'll look better your first day is a
14 year old i can't believe it
your deep voice dad did say last night
you're gonna wake up with you you know
deep voice
color oh yeah you did say that you're
like one inch taller and a deeper voice
that was deeper ready yeah 14 is pretty
cool so far nice i'm glad you're
enjoying your birthday so far enjoy your
breakfast because gotta go to school
[Music]
dad made me a burrito too i'm eating my
homemade juicy pudding and
my homemade granola that i made last
night so isaac
how many days ago last friday and today
is wednesday i jumped the wall at my
school and i landed on both my hands and
i couldn't have been i haven't been able
to walk properly ever since yeah so he
kind of like sprained his heel i guess
he bruised it or something yeah like
bruised his heel today he woke up and
it's feeling a little bit worse huh took
a heavy pro figure just doesn't kick in
yet
i'd say like 20 minutes and then
hopefully this bandaging helps too
thanks for doing it of course
we added another balloon by the way
just to like balance it right
there take the emphasis off of that he
said i have three testicles now
take your test drive
you're all limping and i can walk normal
all the time oh i hate so much lucky
normal
[Music]
what you doing
leftover costume
i made you made a burrito we made a
tattoo egg burrito oh nice
onion oh you have onion breath nice
your favorite i'm going to close my
burrito properly because it's bursting
from the sides
uh oh yeah you like to jam pack your
burritos we should buy the big big
tortillas you should where do you buy
those at i don't know do they have the
wheat kind
no idea but i made myself
a greek yogurt with banana
some
condensed milk and strawberry so yeah
right now we're just gonna squeeze in a
small snack i totally went overboard i
made way too much for myself um but yeah
we're gonna just eat a little snack
really quick
because we're gonna start making lunch
for isaac to come home to
and we're gonna we're gonna be making
his favorite which is pasta and what
some brussels sprouts yes well his
favorite's actually salad but we have a
lot of greens here and so we're going to
do brussels sprouts anyway
what was i going to say oh yeah the
fridge is finally repaired the guy
finally came today he was on vacation
for three weeks and there's also like
covet hit all the repair people so they
weren't able to come for a really long
time but luckily we have that
refrigerator outside so i wasn't
stressing too hard but yeah this fridge
hasn't been working properly for like
two months three months two months two
and a half months i don't know but we
got a new motherboard in there and some
new fan or something i don't know
luckily
the guy came today because i was like
are they gonna cancel on me because they
already canceled me twice this this
thing is now should be now working
properly
we'll see
[Music]
all right it is time to make isaac's
birthday pasta but before i begin i just
want to say a huge thank you to
butcherbox for sponsoring today's video
now you know me i love grilling meats i
love barbecuing i love smoking meats
anything to do with cooking i love but
as i'm getting older i'm starting to
taste the difference in the higher
quality meats and what's more important
it makes me feel better when i eat
higher quality meat and obviously i'm
going to want to feed my family higher
quality meat so when butcher box reached
out to me to partner up how could i say
no so what is butcher box butcher box is
a meat subscription that sources from
farmers and fishermen who meet the
highest standards of quality they
deliver 100 grass-fed beef free-range
organic chicken humanely raised pork and
wild caught seafood straight to your
door if you want higher quality meat at
an affordable price click my link in the
description below all new members will
receive two pounds of grass-fed ground
beef for the lifetime of their
membership so speaking of making pasta
for isaac i'm gonna be making some
ground beef for him today because well
oh it's in the meat sauce that i'm gonna
be making but yeah you can customize the
meat in your box as well as a delivery
frequency so you can get exactly what
you want when you want it butcher box
also ships your order at peak freshness
so everything comes
frozen
and all this comes packed in an
eco-friendly 100 recyclable box
[Music]
all right
it is now much later now we're heading
out and where do you think we're going
i have no clue it's a surprise
we can close it for you please it's like
you guys are dressing fancy
all right are we dressy i'm like the
least dressed out of all of us i mean oh
i'm wearing just a sweater i mean i
didn't put makeup on that should tell
you a lot all right dad he looks good
too lucy oh
i just like getting dressed up because i
work from home these days and never go
out so it's like and tis the occasion to
look better than being at home yeah
dad's dressed as if he's going my way
really gonna have a barnyard wedding
then
very low-key uh not very casual wedding
what about me i don't look like i'm
going to a wedding at all i'm pulling up
i want to see if you figure out where
we're going where are we going
really skydiving no are we
think so are we
that's super cool i've always wanted to
man this teenager isaac it's funny
you're just like super playing it cool
what do you mean we're here so you can
do some indoor skydiving for your
birthday
awesome thank you mom yay
dude i'm so jealous because i've always
wanted to do this i've done the real
skydiving but never indoor skydiving
really yeah i'm so excited for you
and i wish i could join you
but i can't
you know what though once your sibling
comes out definitely coming back i'm
joining you cool you get to put on a
suit and everything
sweet
yeah you're all set my boy
i'm so excited for him you're jealous of
it i'm very jealous
i wish i could be jumping too it's okay
and this baby will cheer from the
sidelines
this is like reigniting my desire to get
my skydiving license i really want to
yeah your real seeker self is is so such
a unique experience like it's so i don't
know it's just like soul searching i
don't know i would love to
have that be like a hobby kind of thing
but it's just very expensive and yes
dangerous and then like some people
they've commented before
like even people that i know like just
they've commented like how can you be so
responsible to skydive when you have a
child
so i'm like i don't know
it's conflicting
here we go
he's like out of control
[Music]
you look like you were having so much
fun was it hard it looked like in the
first one it was like what i thought i
thought i was doing absolutely trash
i thought you got a little bit dizzy at
the end oh yeah
how was
i'd say it's the same um are you
hanging in there like a champ
we're actually at benihanas i've been
wanting to go for a while this is dad's
idea so he had the idea to do indoor
skydiving and wait actually we both had
the idea for benihana because i know
that you've been wanting to do this um
tepping what is it teppanyaki or kenyaki
yeah there's another word too i forgot i
don't know i forgot the word oh
no i forgot anyway
and so we're like oh this is perfect for
your birthday then yeah
so you get to see chefs
perform in front of you
i don't know who that is yeah media
yeah we get to see some tricks tonight
hibachi
the other term that's used around this
style of restaurant let's go
[Music]
[Music]
he's practicing
[Music]
so join butcher box today by clicking my
link in the description down below for a
high quality meet at an affordable price
and remember all new members will
receive two pounds of grass-fed beef for
the lifetime of their membership
so sign up today
[Music]
[Music]